hello alright passage and welcome to
another episode of the Friday games
review I as always in Dan Galpin and
with me we have Daniel Pham guys are you
doing and today we're going to be
looking at Asian RPG these are both
Japanese and Korean RPGs which has
become very very popular in google play
and here on the producer cam we have ian
lewis who is going to be not only
chiming in with important and incisive
comments but also pouring the beers for
us today absolutely so yeah let me go
ahead and take care of my most important
duty right now today we are pouring
something that I think our resident
foreigner should probably uh name for us
so we're talking about rato here we
haven't actually seen yet let's make
that clear ver audience yeah very good
ok actually brewed right here I'm in the
valley san jose california actually um
home of me and also hobos can get packed
heart with samurai swords that was our
big news story of the week and it's good
how to keep this show topical
that's right oh my and the yeah you talk
to any changes I was wearing this hat
here the san jose sharks but I a big
shout out to scout who is an APM here
who loaned me this hat for the show we
were trying to figure out what would be
the proper show to wear a giant red
squid hat for and somehow hey wow it's
nice somehow this Bend this 11 the straw
so today we're we're gonna eat it it is
it is a good it is a good hat good yeah
oh oh yes please here we can we get the
compost glasses for me rather than the
the fabulous oktoberfest glass that is a
fantastic google oktoberfest fun you
guys people should see this yeah there
we are yep so it's great to have Daniel
aboard here and to be here thank you
thank you and we've had we've had a lot
of fun playing the games this week one
thing about these asian rpgs in general
is it takes a long time to actually get
into the game and yeah i mean in just
the the 40 hours I've had that's a good
place you know I really couldn't get a
really in-depth look at any one title at
Inger acquires hundreds of hundreds of
hours to just to get it actually it with
the best part Final Fantasy three
actually which is one of the ones we're
looking today you know shipped on google
play and there are a bunch of review
that said the game was only a couple of
hours long and that is because a couple
of people only played through the intro
and after the intro it actually plays
the credit and then it goes on to play
the other 30 hours of gameplay or so so
these are these are really deep
intensive games another thing that's
interesting about all these games and
really going to be looking at for today
all four of these games are originally
ports from other platforms so a lot of
the experience on Android is colored by
how deep the port operation actually got
and so final fantasy 3 I believe came
over from the DS the rest of them from
the PlayStation Portable and it's
possible is the noni afore I don't know
if it actually appeared on anything else
so
that one it's just the style certainly
of that game and we also have really
three distinct styles of gameplay here
we have final fantasy 3 which is a
turn-based fighting game but without
without significant you know adore deep
tactics we have spectral souls which is
a deep deeply tactical turn-based
fighting game and then we have arcade
style role-playing games which are an
OSHA 3 in zenonia force we really do
have quite a variety of gameplay all
under the general umbrella of Asian RPGs
and and I there's a lot of things that
are that are very specific to this style
of gameplay deep story is what drives
the game there are certainly RPG
elements and they vary depending on the
game we also different monetization
strategies across these four games so we
can talk a little bit about interMune oh
what the impact of the specific porting
that was done as well as a little bit of
the of the game playing styles itself so
let's start off with a game to game we
played the most which is Final Fantasy
three I think both Daniel and I are old
old fans and why don't why don't why
don't I will bring this up and I'd like
you know Daniel to chime in on this one
sure so what's interesting about this
game is they actually are supporting two
different modes of saved game within the
game you can actually quick save and you
can also which uses kind of a save state
and you can do that anywhere within the
game but it also supports what was
traditionally in the game with slave
site herbs to save cycle save slots so
you can see we've got continuing new
game and load game continue just goes
into the last quick save one thing
that's one thing to note in this game if
you don't actually save slots you
actually when you die you die so it is
actually important to use the old-school
saved game system definitely I made that
mistake first time playing through this
game
and it was a little bit annoying but
it's a little bit to talk to a modern
game or not used to a game where we
actually are killed off after 10 hours
of gameplay and suddenly have to start
over and instantly reminded of
battletoads that's a game for another
day exactly so another thing you'll
notice is that we're looking here at the
at the typical screen and although we're
slightly covering the only controls that
are there you see there aren't actually
a significant number of controls on the
screen the controls are actually
activated when we touch the screen and
you know very much this style of
gameplay now this this again is a remake
of the original final fantasy 3 which
showed up on the 8-bit nintendo
entertainment system or famicom and in
fact i don't think it ever shipped in
the united states other than other than
through some very creative people who
who produced english translations of
this and it wasn't really until we got
into the later final fantasy games that
we actually started numbering them
appropriate in the US i could be wrong
that's my that's my recollection here so
the game itself is is is pretty
straightforward we're inside of a town
right now we can exit the town and in
final fantasy true epicness we actually
have a flying machine that we can use to
fly around the world map this by the way
is the intro part of the game just just
just to let you know this is the first
section of the game where we actually
have to free this town where everyone
has been turned into ghosts from the
clutches of of this gin and we have to
get some myth myth rings and all sorts
of fun stuff like that and it really
they've done a marvelous job with this
remake from from the DS I'm sorry did
you say clutches of it up Jim of a
hahaha yes of a DJI nn okay Oh suddenly
a lost interest okay so um yeah we lost
our viewers right yeah
they thought we were talking about
alcohol for a moment there it's so
there's there there there's beautiful
little in-game cutscenes and it's
interesting they've actually chosen you
know it's part you may not be able to
tell this from looking at the graphics I
run through the game but they've
actually chosen to keep the game
unfiltered for the most part so you'll
see that the graphics look kind of look
instead of looking blurry they look
intentionally blocky and that was really
nice a nice patch by them and back of
the cutscenes you know I was really
impressed by that I didn't expect
something like that I'm out of an
android game but maybe I we just had
poor experiences playing play android
games in general exactly we need to get
you plenty more android games as clearly
as clearly but yeah they've done it's
really it's really beautifully done
they've also done a very good job of
integrating most of the Android features
the FF probably the only really
confusing thing is again the old-school
elements of the game which you
definitely have to get used to if you
haven't played this sort of game in a
while we have for some of our younger
viewers and they not be familiar with
the style of that this game is shown in
absolutely and so talk about the things
that we're done they're done well one of
things I really enjoy is that even
though the game has old-school
unfiltered graphics if you look at the
font you can see the font is rendered at
full resolution independently of the
game and that makes the game feel so
much better because your eyes aren't
trying to focus on a font that's blurry
or filtered and it's also not trying to
you not looking at something it's really
really low resolution and it really fits
in quite well with with the game even
with the old-school graphics you can see
that both on the font there in the text
as well as on the map and menu icons
which were sort of covering up with our
with our current view here in the corner
so there are some things that are sort
of interesting about this you know one
is this is that we hit the back key we
get close application okay first of all
it's a little jarring because we
actually end up getting getting a
dialogue that is a system dialogue
rather than our own it's also a dialogue
that's not a honeycomb dial not a hollow
style dialog so so we're
we're kind of thrown out of there you
can see we actually have at the bottom
of the screen of this digital menu key
that doesn't do anything I do I touch it
it doesn't do anything and we also have
the Zoom button over here which which
through which allows us to stretch or
zoom in to make it as if we were playing
this on an old school device so all of
this could easily be corrected of course
by simply targeting a more recent
version in terms of the menu and the
zoom and as far as the back key is
concerned in this case it really just
makes sense to go back to the main menu
since you can continue this would be a
perfect opportunity to quick save go
back to the main menu would be much much
less jarring for the user now there you
know there is if you quick safe within
the game you'll note it's a little
confusing to you cut the quick save
button you say yes perform quick save
and it does immediately then kick you
out of the game and take you back to the
title screen because and quick save is
really what it does when you when you
exit the game in the middle of playing
it so so that so by doing that you go
back this is prop this is what the
default behavior should be it probably
should pop up something let you let you
know that your quick saving and then
take you back to the title screen if you
hit the back key yeah a little bit more
warning um yeah I mean you know get it
you know quick saving because it's
because it's such a simple thing to
quick save you know in this in this case
for you for the end user and it's very
easy it's very straightforward you just
hit continue it can be done with it with
with really really minimal kind of
prompting so there's a lot of there's a
lot of work that goes in here to prompt
the user to try to help these are out
the reality is what mostly what they
want to do is just immediately quick
save when they hit that back key similar
to what happens if you hit the HOME key
and then the game is closed it actually
will quick say for you if you're in the
middle of gameplay so that that's
something I would definitely look at in
terms of in terms of being able to you
know this just interact that much more
smoothly with Android another thing is
all I'll go here back to so I right now
exited I'm going back to the main screen
here which you know is one again once
again as a general rule
not you want to be able to continue past
all of these things here at the
beginning it's just you hit the back key
here close application it's not really
necessary if you're on the title screen
so this is just something I would
definitely like to see them clean up and
you know again I think everything else
we get here is in this game is really
just it's vestigial from its original
origins you have a limited number of
save slots you have and the game really
is about knowing when to save making
sure you have saved at appropriate times
and and it's it's very traditional your
object is not to complete the story but
it's also to avoid death yes death is
very painful in this game and can cause
you hours and hours of hours of having
redo things say big time but pre-staged
don't then to save your progress because
you can only have one slot and the game
deletes the quicksave slot when you die
yes so so again that you know it's very
very much about juggling those internal
slots I think it's a little bit of a
little bit confusing to a user of the
game that you have to you have to juggle
these kind of two independent mechanisms
I'm sorry but but it is really good that
they have that and it definitely made
today you know kind of a mobile and
complete title the other game that I
think is really interesting it's close
to the same Jean closest to the same
genre its spectral souls and spectral
souls is an epic and a huge huge game
thank you for changing they yes yeah I
also have to mention that the developers
of spectral souls are probably my
favorite developers ever so Carlo and
that other dude that I can't remember
whose buddies with Carlo you had you
gave us the most epic night of drinking
at the at the Marriott sky bar ever who
is us by the way I was not bad no that
was I wasn't there you there yeah well
so so it's true the dan fam was not
there
dan galpin left early yes before we
found what does happen exactly Android
in the corner that was six feet tall and
the CEO of spry Fox put it on and went
dancing around the bar that was a good
night and that was a little bit of an
edited version from what I heard earlier
yeah absolutely that was that but that
was good that was good editing for our
family viewers umm so so spectral souls
back to the game but but we've had we've
had a the good thing is that we've had a
long relationship with these developers
they've done a really really good job of
taking a really epic game from the
PlayStation Portable and bring it here
but but you do see a lot of vestiges of
what they had to do one of them is if
you look at the on-screen controls here
you see that you have you know a
constant on-screen HUD of arrow keys and
the arrow keys are actually fairly far
apart here on this tablet if you look
here on on what is uh I believe you're
are you left hand side of the screen I
guess we're seeing a mirror here so and
and so you'll see they're actually
fairly far apart and you'd actually want
those to be closer together on a town on
a tablet of this screen size but on a
phone there in about the right there and
they're about the right size and
orientation the rest of the buttons are
actually pretty good on the tablet
although you do have to reach fairly far
if you're actually trying to control it
with two hands to get to the start
button there in the center and then you
have buttons that are anonymously enable
enable labeled a b c and d with no
indication of what their function might
be be normally goes back as part of the
mystery again it is part of the mystery
of up and so part of your job in this
and you know i think if you're the kind
of gamer who enjoys this kind of game is
to try to puzzle out how the user
interface works as you're playing the
game also the game is very very deep if
you're used to final fantasy levels of
combat this is much more like final
fantasy tactics where we're there really
is a lot of tactical element to the come
to the combat itself the goal is to
chain attacks in order to in order to
inflict maximum damage and also the
the terrain is very very important there
actually are hills in the train in
elevation and you actually have to move
strategically to sometimes cut off other
pleather characters sometimes to
surround them properly so you can a
chain chain attacks appropriately so
there's really a lot of strategy in this
game we're very very early in this game
in this scene here some doodle notes
again was coming coming back to its
PlayStation Portable origins we do see
this incredibly low res font here that
they've chosen to you also you notice
they've chosen to filter all of their
graphics the HUD is in very high res
it's very very nice by the way though
all the elements they've added are
definitely there but in terms of you
know it is a little bit jarring to have
that in there in terms of it would be
great if they could figure out a way of
actually modifying the engine to to
support some higher res text or perhaps
just not filtering the text in this
particular case i think i think the
filtering is actually diminishing from
the impact of of the text within the
game and you know and really the only
other comments i have are our comments
about you know what about the HUD and
just baking the game a little bit
cleaner in terms of being able to have
people understand the controls you know
it it once you realize that you're
playing a game that includes a set of
random buttons and you have to kind of
figure out what they do in different
situations and the game is consistent
with how they're used because of course
it was consistent on the original game I
think you do figure that out you can see
like all the all the screens they have
in the game are all are all in a very
very simple nondescript but you know
look again a nice use you're actually
seeing this is a dialog hitting the back
key again doesn't do anything it should
so these are just little you know when
you're reporting these games it's always
it's always tricky to figure out what to
do in each one of these situations and
you know if we were going to look at
this today and in terms of featuring
they would definitely say hey that back
he should then pop them back out of that
pause screen or move them back to the to
the main screen of the game rather than
stopping them there but in general it's
you know it's for what it is is a very
good game also note that this
game has an enormous enormous enormous
secondary download and this is this is
this this this game was one of the first
enormous games to ship yes so that if
we're downloading this game plan to go
get a cup of coffee took a bathroom
break watch the TV show something along
those lines before you can actually play
it yeah as I recall you guys I can't you
like play pong while you're downloading
yes I had one of the one of the cool
things the developers have done is you
actually they implemented pong now
unfortunately it's it's it's as far as i
can tell it's impossible to win their
game of pong you can't you can play it
during the download and that brought
back some great memories as well so yeah
and it's very cool it actually gives you
progress I think it does win for the
coolest downloader on Android yeah by
far alright i just also want to point
out yes that we have just regained the
amount of viewers that we lost while i
was telling my carlopa kranti getting
drunk in the marriott story haha so I
just thought I'd break in to see if my
face on the the TV is actually going to
lose us four or five more viewers I
think people are just enjoyed I think
people are in suspense as to whether or
not this squid has actually a fall off
my head at some point in turn sliding
backwards a little bit it is this is a
very challenging hat to wear so I don't
think people are waiting to see whether
it falls off their way to see if it
starts to become self animated oh that's
possible yeah it could it could become
self aware during the show you know I
will say this i I'm been watching the
YouTube live stream and actually if you
guys are watching on YouTube live there
is a live stream comments where I'm like
pathetically typing hey dude anybody
there what some questions and stuff like
that um I feel a little bad myself
actually but the i would say out of
about 20 comments about 12 of them are
praising dance hat all right there yeah
the squid hat is a huge winner alright
the other hand we weren't into our G+
stream the Android beanie
clear loser really people do what I
android they know they do not but it's
because they felt that it was a poor
quality Android beanie and you could do
better dan all right there we are back
you are pretty loose when I see getting
even better has a better beanies so uh
yeah I don't really have that much more
to say about spectral souls because i
only played it for about four hours and
it really takes a long time to get
farther into the game so i can only i
can only assume the story stays
engrossing and fun as it certainly was
from the start so that gets us through i
think the two that i would describe is
Japanese RPGs that are that are that are
in this set and now we also have two
Korean RPGs as well the two I enjoyed a
little bit more than kind of first two
so oh yeah actually i did i'm more of a
fan of arcade-style games no i I've I'm
ADHD it's not I know I don't actually
have any I'm boy I feel I feel like we
should have some music here as you age
you know tell us stories about how that
has impacted your life till I go on but
let me rephrase i have a short attention
span in these games i've managed it to
keep my attention a lot better than the
first year that yeah and so we've got
you've got to example of this genre we
have an ocean three and has been calm to
us and this game was really i think i
think it really set the bar high for
korean rpgs coming to android it was
really the first one that i was excited
about and yes later but good that it
didn't force me to join their to do that
as a general rule so we can continue the
game because i'm a level four barbarians
for anyone you've played the game knows
that means i haven't played that far on
this tablet so some general notes here
and we've to actually talked about an
ocean it in our previous episodes i
don't need to go over this in great
detail obviously on the on the tablet
the HUD is huge it
enormous and it's low res and in these
is you're controlling the character you
can see I really do have to move my
finger quite a long way across the
tablet in order to actually use this
controller that is here on the left hand
side also we're seeing you know once
again evident that this this game was
was a port is you know the the the
graphics are very very low resolution
for modern devices now that doesn't
really take away from the charm of the
game very much you know and I you know I
certainly would not want them to you
know not bring this game to Android just
because of that I think it I think I've
done a really really nice job with it
with the original pixel art on the game
and it's really quite charming the the
basic game is controlled using
essentially a single button control with
a bunch of pop-up buttons that have
different actions and this is this is
also very very you know really very
straightforward very intuitive you can /
things or it with your action button and
there's also a series of action controls
the game involves a lot of repetitive
actions so ads are as you see placed
into the game with this is I believe an
ad-supported game only then if you want
two people to be able to see the
controls if you actually take the Galaxy
Nexus out of that plastic container and
put the tablet in there then people be
able to see your hands as well ah that's
a good point all right so I guess we
can't actually just hold it well if you
use a preset one you can actually hold
it ends at made preset one a little
tricky okay we should shoot show show us
because everyone it's just you know what
yeah all the precepts because it does
yeah the pebble has come loose you want
to fix that oh yes that's a good point
there you go see beautiful is and that
is glorious alright fabulous so you can
actually see the the HUD and how long it
actually the amount of distance I do
actually have to move my fingers across
to change the direction so we definitely
want to see the fact this is a large
screen device being taken advantage of
I'd like to see the hyvee higher
resolution as well generally fonts in
the game you know be higher resolution
as well and because I do they do feel
blurry on this device but but the
controls are fun you actually have an
option of using kind of these special
attacks here as
y la year you know I really liked the
control mechanism that I can put match
all day long on the game like this and
get results but you're right that the
the HUD size does make a little
difficult to smash all the buns at the
same time that's right something I used
to love doing a street fighter to you
just button mash all day but again very
very very similar in style to go into
buildings we have this working in you
know a different building view which
makes this building I mean from the
outside this building looks actually
quite small from the inside the building
is enormous and that's also i would say
something that is a something that I
didn't even notice the fusion machine
that's cool this is this is how you
synthesize things also notice heating
the back here does not pull me adequate
is very opposite dialogue in the game
there's an on-screen back control so her
about a billion reasons that the android
market sorry Google Play all right
artists that's a drink every time i say
android market the Google Play team I'll
ring for you thank you ah the Google
Play team would have lots to say about
this before before featuring it but it
is really a very well very well done
game in the genre but another thing the
game does do is it one of the first
quests in the game there are lots of
quests and such a game is broken up is
to actually send you back to Google Play
to rate the game and if you break the
game yeah if you actually go and take
that quest it pops up google play and
then it gives you some special potions
and as we probably mentioned before that
is actually against the policy of play
maybe a little bit sad they did it did
at least they're not asking you for a
five star rating but they are I would
have been ranked the game yeah in return
for you know giving you something within
the game as a general rule you know we
love games and encourage people to route
to review just try it out to incentivize
them other than
you know saying yes if you liked our
game review us and if I am going to
review a game I want a little bit better
than incentive than just some potions
haha you look a cool cool cold or
something someone can contact daniel
offline for incentives on 4 ratings yeah
please yeah please send me a message
online like make sure it's at least a
sword or some cool armor or something
custom graphics not again I'm going to
pull it off here because it's too hard
to keep hdmi actually going so we're not
going to back to be able to use that
camera anymore but you know the game
really is deep it has quite a lot going
for it uh so with the final game that
we're actually looking at we're going
through these you know pretty quickly
here is from our friends over at
Gainesville and and their name is
Antonio sup crisis in don't leave depart
and return of the legend and we're I was
excited about ski for a lot of reasons
one of it is it it's just beautiful high
beautiful pixel art I loved it I loved
it the art was amazing everything is
high resolution the controls are really
easy it's it's I hate to say this but
it's almost a more polished version of
the Comte less game oh yeah it is it is
definitely you know is definitely a
later a later game you can see it I've
got it actually makes use of vibration
when I'm doing this and actually I'm
printed pretty far in the game here
we're already several hours in the game
I'm level six and you know again the
game is very high resolution I would
still like to see higher response they
still are a bit a bit blurry and one of
the nice thing about this game is that
you'll notice actually and I should have
mentioned that before when talking about
in ocean three that you actually do see
artifacts due to basically filtering
where it's actually where it's actually
blurring stuff that's outside of the
current yeah that's right the games you
see like little pixels three pixels here
you don't see any of that in this game
and it's just it's it looks beautiful at
this resolution so I don't know another
thing i want to note is that this game
and the last game you can skip through a
lot of the the cutscenes so you're not a
fan of story driven games and you want
to skip right to the action and
definitely do that in other words if you
have a short attention span missing
games and that's why i love these games
that's why i love them right to the
action exactly skip all the stuff now
for me this guy will say that you know
it from a gameplay perspective there was
a little bit too much of i walk off the
screen and i walk back on and all like
all the monsters are back and i know
that's a you know important part of the
element of this of the sort of game and
it certainly gives you the unlimited
ability to keep leveling up but i did
find a little frustrating now it's not
better way to use potions by the way
than going to your inventory here and
actually kicking use potion I couldn't
find ok I I was like really that's how I
have to do this but you know maybe maybe
maybe if you have someone there is this
plus button here but it doesn't seem to
help so there you know as I was I was
really hoping for something better
within the HUD to say hey I really want
to use a potion because I'm almost dead
yeah and there was no way that was those
was one of my complaints as well that if
you're in the middle of a 5 monster
fight and you want to use a potion is
kind of annoying that to go into the
menu screen yeah it is jarring and again
though you know big action button I
think it's interesting to to to look at
this and compare this against me know
what we saw in in final fantasy 3 which
had really really minimal displaying
controls on screen and you know this we
have lots and lots of stuff all over the
screen you know and it you know it
they're both very effective I think this
in some ways is more intuitive but I
really like the minimalist approach and
once you've actually played the game for
just a few minutes you do figure out
fairly quickly well its many buttons on
the screen I know you know you know it
is somewhat intuitive buns on the screen
it's like when you have this many
buttons i just started starts to get
tricky what you're actually doing so
i've had a question for you Dan first
based on some things that we're seeing
on the YouTube live stream yes I how are
the controls on this can
heard too inotia I I think they're
they're a little easier the controls are
a little closer together so I find it's
a little easier on a tablet they still
have the same basic problem though that
they aren't scaling the signs of the
d-pad for the tablet which I like they
really should be scaling that and would
you like to explain to our developers
the best way to do that sure so what
we're talking about here is this device
is a large screen device which has a
screen resolution of any DPI sorry I
between yeah density of what we call
mdpi which is about 150 pixels per inch
and so we were trying to do when
wherever we decide one of these controls
we're actually looking to size them
based approximately on the size of your
finger in this case we're trying to look
what is a comfortable motion now the
good news about this particular Hut is
it really is a good compromise between
form and function it works very it works
well enough because the controls are all
placed close to the edge on both sides
so it's actually very very easy to reach
all of the controls within the game and
so it's not it's a it's a little bit
better than what's going on with with
inotia which has controls are that are
farther out and much much better than
what was going on with spectral souls or
you had controls just spread across the
whole screen even though spectral souls
had these very very beautiful high res
controls which I really really liked
having spread across the sea many things
challenging because they put the buttons
in the corners they actually work fairly
well on a tablet on a tablet here and
you can actually see but I was the cable
out again no sorry guys it's again when
when rato was making that motion it
wasn't dirty then put people back in dan
right right exactly so I also have one
more question and it's just based on
what I'm seeing from the screenshots
here keep in mind that I haven't
actually played this game
but as far as I can tell on these on the
screen when you're in the action you are
apparently a fairly young child wearing
a cowboy hat and carrying a gigantic gun
yes I'm but but in the cutscenes or when
you're actually talking to somebody you
are apparently a cross between Billy
Idol and Britney Spears so can you
explain that well it's interesting you
mentioned that actually again in the
game's storyline it is actually
mentioned that the character is
surprised that he looks like a child and
he's actually been brought back in time
so there is they do actually try to
justify the childlike experience however
there they are talking about the
somewhat older child that appears in the
cutscenes rather than the than the very
young child now this kind of squashed
art style is a hallmark of both Japanese
and and Korean role playing games and so
that you know having have any character
run around in this sort of wide-eyed
childlike form is definitely a signature
element of these games and I think a lot
of the reason is the characters are
small and they wanted to differentiate
them very very easily and if they
actually tried to make them look more
adult there's that there's fewer pixels
to draw eyes or see where pictures draw
facial features and so it became easier
in these games to differentiate them by
having these kind of squashed cartoony
forms and large head exactly so that's
that's and this is just stayed now and
become part of the art form even though
we don't need it you know III don't I'm
not gonna argue with that but you can't
explain the bare midriff you just can't
his yeah I thought it was interesting
news that his dad also walks around in a
fairly shirtless way and and I thought I
thought it was sort of to to to you know
make him be more childlike is his dad is
like this that you know that the 12-pack
going and he has like this the other set
I don't know anyone father's a thousand
other elements of this game we could be
reviewing but we're looking at the the
bare midriff and
that's a short was dead well you know we
are following Ian's interest here so so
any case so things to note in this game
one is the backe pops up and says quick
game and go to main menu with again a
system dialogue we or do we do once
again have have the vestigial Menu key
we have the zoom in key it's always fun
to actually push this and see what
happens you know does the game in size
every different game yeah you know no I
suspect this game is just gonna be
massively unhappy now that we've done
this but we'll see it's always n so it's
always a Toby's interesting so we're
here this is what the game would look
like if you're running it like on an
ancient device by the way extra let's do
back I don't want to do a new game let's
do continue so and again a lot of people
say well you know how do you how does
pixel art scale and you know we can't
possibly do a game with you know you
know that's that that supports different
screens on Android because pixel art
doesn't scale it just looks terrible and
when it has to go down to lower
resolutions especially this style of art
this is the one people complain about
the most because it's got outlines on it
to be honest this is totally playable
like I would not be embarrassed at all
on a road on a device with this low
resolution having to actually have this
style of art so this is just just a note
out to you gain developers you know it's
not nearly as bad as you think i just
died and so so i'm gonna quit the game
now that i'm now that i've died extreme
action RPG and that fact you the way the
game on is you actually you can buy
things that allow you to resurrect
yourself so the game is kind of focused
on death because death is how they make
money and all these one of the ways they
make money within the game there's also
maybe that's why the potions are so hard
to get to it's possible that's what i
was i was curious i I don't I don't like
to be the one who's you know being the
one mounting conspiracy theories but
that's certainly a possibility that i
considered so yeah you know from from a
perspective of the game you know having
having that that menu key just really
doesn't help them but it does actually
you know allow us to talk about
something which i think is kind of fun
which is you know exactly how a game
does support multiple screen Scott
Elle's multiple screen resolutions and
as you can see it's really not that bad
even for a game that's as high
resolution is this to actually scale
down to an incredibly low resolution
we're zooming in there we are going down
to original g1 resolutions yeah but if
you want to avoid having that in your
game it's actually quite easy you simply
have to make sure that you have the
manifest saying that you support all
screens and that you're targeting or
recent version of the SDK so it's it's
you know get that out of your game your
game doesn't need it the game looks
beautiful without it and don't give a
user the reason a reason to push that
button and crash your game it's just not
worth it and the game by the way doesn't
have to crash that just the game not
handling the resize message
appropriately so I wanted to met and
take a brief mention we didn't have a
couple of other games that were
nominated and I know that this was a
very very narrow nomination pool here we
had a we had parallel mafia which really
is not fit into Asian RPG models it does
have some artwork that's kind of a i
would say reminiscent of this but it
really falls into a totally different
category of game so sorry to say you
know we're not looking at it the same
thing with with my kingdom for a
princess is that what it is i believe
called yeah we're waiting for the print
yeah my kingdom well it's a long time
it's a long title for the princess um I
can be the princess three yes and which
also falls into that category now i will
said i did try to look at this game I
put a long time trying to get it to
download and you can see it we're on the
download screen now and as you see there
it fought it downloaded part of it and
then went back and it failed and it's
redownloading again the game might be
really beautiful it certainly this title
screen is gorgeous the developers at you
know this is a very very popular
developer with a lot of popular titles
so I would love to have a look at it but
it but a but if it but if a downloader
does not properly resume and this one
does not seem to at least in the three
times that I've had it fail and yes it
is restarted completely that's going to
keep people from playing your game and
so it's something you know it's a shame
to spend the thousands of hours in
developing you know a game title like
this only to do not have
method of getting the game to the user
now the other thing of course I would
say is that because this is on google
play we really should be using apk
expansion files to deliver the other
content that way Google Play will
automatically deliver the content to the
device for you and you don't have to
worry about having this download or now
if you do have content that you're
trying to split across different screen
resolutions there's a limited amount of
that kid that can be done using the AP
cake multiple apk facility within google
play and but in general i think i think
for the vast majority of these games is
not necessary to even do that i think
that that we're at a point now with
modern hardware with scaling pixel art
looks pretty good even yep so i just
want to do a brief mention of those two
why we're not having them on the show
but it's always kind of important to me
that you know the things get delivered
in a way that's good for the user I will
say one nice thing about my kingdom for
the princess is that it does not have
the vestigial zoom control although it
does have this digital menu I also want
to say that I did get a chance to play
para la mafia and it is a very
entertaining game but we can cover it in
a different in different show we cover
miscellaneous games it's more of a
mash-up type of game it's like a MMO
combined with a little bit of RPG with
localization um geographical and
regional elements to it too so you don't
want to when I looked at her la mafia um
I really felt like it was representative
of what i think is kind of a new genre
of games I think we're calling the
location based games so for instance red
robot labs has a game called life is
crime that's very similar there's a
couple other games out there that are
like this where you're basically playing
on a real map so it might be actually
really cool to do a show just around
location-based games it's pretty new
genre though I don't know if we'll have
enough but titles to look at yeah I
think I think they're think that's going
to be a great idea and I certainly want
to see more innovation in the gay in the
mobile game space I think one of the
unique things about being on these
mobile platforms is we carry them around
with us and
and so that does open up a whole bunch
of new gaming plus potentials plus there
is a lot of opportunity for promoting
local businesses within a game and and
and and monetization as well so I think
I think it's a really interesting
category both in terms of gameplay as
well as in terms of you know finding new
ways of monetizing games so I think
that's we're going we're going to have a
short show today I know there's anything
else we want to say we do of course
always value your input on on our
moderator page so please continue to
nominate games for our next few weeks we
do have a few more weeks lined up and
and will continue to hopefully be here
yeah my beer um give me no one for next
week no but uh yeah we do but that's
that's right folks we are having a short
show today our show is only going three
minutes overtime yeah and before we
before we leave yes we do have a show
next week we do have a topic for it it
escapes me at the moment what it is I do
know the week after next week you know
we're gonna be targeting NFL apps that's
right games week after next but it's all
about alcohol not ratos kind of phone no
no our kind of foucault next real kind
of phone next to next week we have us
between his brain and puzzle right sorry
for before we leave next week is baiting
puzzle games but Oh Brandon yeah
actually braided puzzle games we have
this request from a viewer that I wanted
to nominate their brain and puzzle game
uh I think that it's great genre and I'm
really really excited to take a look at
that I will be back here next week um I
set out this show doing the producer
thing because I am if nothing not an
Asian RPG fan but before so it's are you
saying that didn't the dango family our
agent correspondent uh uh yeah he's our
token asian thanks guys yeah
hey any VP I or em RPGs just you guys
yes you guys can guess all right anyway
uh moderator page you guys can vote
that's all right what's an evasion do
you think Daniel yes I'm gonna make if
you think I and also I just want to make
sure that everybody holds up their beer
uh before we before we leave yeah how
much is Dan drunk how much does Dan
drunk no not very much uh-uh hard to
tell in this but I think I've got a
backward Bob so I'm not not too well
yeah why yeah I didn't use yeah well
we're both dan do you see that that's
that's what works out I think dan we've
not broken until he loses the deposit on
his apartment so the yeah yeah guys
thanks for tuning in thanks a lot for I
for being on the live stream um by the
way I do have to mention so there's some
great comments right at the end of the
live stream first I think the end galpin
should be drinking more beer that's a
great oh I love that comment the other
ones are uh it would be great to review
something like the old-school elite oh
my god I have to tell you that is so
true elite was my favorite game ever did
you leave that comment yeah that sounds
like a coming moves out someone else's
left then calm much i think in created a
new account signed in at himself just to
post that cause I to create an account
it would not be named Dennis p boost no
no offense to the Dennis p boosters of
this world but that just wouldn't be my
first choice there you go I would
probably go for I don't know dance cute
let's go you me all right said yeah
anyway uh so yeah elite and rogue
actually were the two suggestions I
think those are both great suggestion
yeah you know rugged is rogue I I think
that almost all of these RPGs that we
looked at today actually do our
descendants of rogue to some degree or
another actually if you play dungeon
hunter three from Gameloft it pretty
much is road with
dated graphics and a couple of
additional elements but uh but yeah I
think I think that they're certainly I
want to see more games that are that are
like elite I'd like to see the
originally come back and some super
awesome I mean he originally come back
as a mobile title yeah and not that you
know okay all prompts to the original
elite authors but when you brought it to
pc and called it frontier it was mistake
yeah you did not do well with that and i
had issues there I was a huge fan of the
Wing Commander games I was a huge fan of
yes hi fighter right you tightwad best
baby I made and after that frontier
mm-hmm absolute and I actually I was a
huge fan of Starflight as well and then
those in that series of games which all
all oh that their legacy to elite so if
you great see that I there's that I also
want to you know as far as early games
that i want to see I very much want to
see Archon come to Android oh yes so
it's a react games you have the license
bring it on all right and that's pretty
much it i think for us on the Friday
review of games again come back keep
nominating brain and puzzle games for us
to look at next week I as always in Dan
Galpin with me is Daniel Pham and of
course we have rato who's do is uh who
is currently running our technical deck
here and we have Ian on producer so
thank you all thank you guys we'll see
you next week and cheers Cheers
you